[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> We have eight minutes
to ask a question..
And we're gonna get there
through tangents, and
we're gonna get there through metaphors.
And we're gonna do it that way because
this guy is a diversion thinker.
And that's a term we're gonna get to
a little bit later on in this talk.
But for now,
the question what do we take when we exit?
This is the road out of this place.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's the view from
the main quad down toward Palo Alto.
And here at the business school,
we have classes about exit strategies.
These classes teach us how to take
an idea, turn it into a product and
exit with that product into a marketplace.
The names for these classes From Idea
to Launch, From Launch to Liquidity.
Dean Saloner is quoting Buzz Lightyear for
next year's seminar,
To Liquidity and Beyond.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Now in order to provide some
context for this question,
I'm going to talk about
an exit that I had in my life.
It was not a liquidity event.
It was the end of my dance career.
So, we're going to step through time.
I'm 21 years old.
I have no college education, and
I'm standing in front of a man who
will be nominated for a Tony Award for
The Color Purple, and he has just
given me this phrase of arm movement.
And he says Aaron,
put that movement into your legs.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And I said Donald, in my head, no!
Arms are not legs!
They do not have the same weights.
They do not have the same joints.
They will not move the same way.
This is crazy.
Outside I go with him on this tangent and
I say, okay.
[LAUGH]
>> I move my leg around,
I step up to it, and I jump back.
As literal of an interpretation
as I can think of, and
Donald says, Aaron,
that's not quite what we're looking for.
How bout make it cuter?
Okay.
Cute I can do.
I put my hands behind my back,
I tap my foot and I stick out my butt.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because, that's what cute does.
And no surprise Donald says,
Aaron that is not a good look for you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Go pelvic floor sexy.
Pelvic floor sexy, okay maybe I can
do that, I swing out my leg and
I turn it around and I jump back and
I thrust forward my pelvis.
And Donald says, better.
This is the illustrative of
an eight year long journey
through tangents and metaphors.
Stark visuals.
Like go pelvic floor sexy.
Move through molasses.
Listen to the rope of your arms.
Cut the air as a feather.
All designs to bring texture, to movement.
Now I loved my life.
And I wasn't thinking about exits.
I was lost in the content of
the words that I was experiencing.
It's no surprise that if you look up
there, pelvis features prominently.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I wasn't thinking about exits
because I thought I had time.
I knew like all athletes, and others, my
career was going to end between 30 and 35.
But as I was thinking I had time,
it turns out I was wrong.
So for this next part of the story
let me put you in my shoes.
It's two days before your 25th birthday.
You wake up, and
you kiss the person sitting next to you.
You pull on blue jeans that you bought
at Good Will three weeks ago and
you walk out into a foggy
San Francisco day.
You get on a bus, you get off the bus, and
at work you exchange those blue jeans, or
blue tights, and you put on canvas ballet
slippers and you tie them tight so
every crevice of that canvas
matches every curve of your foot,
and you put your leg up on that bar and
you stretch, and
you watch as the sun burns off the clouds
into what is turning into a beautiful day.
Your boss comes up behind you.
His name is Michael Smuin,
and he has shock white hair.
He's put digital dance moves on Yoda,
he's choreographed for
Francis Ford Coppola and
he says to you, next year,
I want to choreograph a ballet for
you, Cyrano, long nose and all.
What a great day.
In the middle of class he says let's
have a jig, petit allegro, small jumps.
And in the middle of the studio you can
feel the glue from those canvas shoes
cover your toes, and you walk to
the side expecting a correction, but
when you look back at the center at
Michael something is very wrong.
Michael isn't breathing.
Your the first one at his side, and
you put an arm over his shoulder, and
you say loudly and
clearly Michael stay with us.
Because you know hearing
is the last thing to go.
You pick him up, and
you put him on the floor, and
you watch as his eyes roll
up into his head and close.
Michael's death, Michael's
exit, it is poetic for many.
This man died doing what he loved.
But, for me, it was a wake up call.
It's hard to make a joke
at this point in the story.
But if you look up at this list.
Pelvis on a resume?
So like many others,
I went to community college.
Monday to Wednesday I was in night school.
Thursday to Sunday I was dancing,
and I was lucky to find myself
here at Stanford University as
an undergraduate at the age of 28.
At the age of 28, I was watching a TED
talk as part of curriculum in a classroom.
Let me say that again so
that you understand.
I was watching a TED talk as
an assignment for a class.
[LAUGH]
>> Sir Ken Robinson was
speaking about the value of creativity,
specifically divergent thinking.
He was talking about divergent thinking
as the process of creating value
from an idea.
And a small light when off in my head,
and it got brighter and
brighter as brighter as I was watching
this laptop, and I thought to myself,
oh my God, my entire dance career,
I was translating ideas into motion,
and that was the value of my life.
I am a divergent thinker.
That label had power.
Here at the GSB,
as we get ready the students to leave,
I ask, what are the labels that we have?
What are the processes that
we do that are different and
could change our lives as
we go out of this place?
And for those of you who are here
today who are not students.
What has just occurred in this room?
What do we take when we exit?
Now when I ask that question I can't
help but think of a few things.
>> I think put my arms in my legs.
>> I think through tangents and metaphors.
>> And I ask,
what do you take when you exit?
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]